alo chào các bạn
ừ ừ
ờ ờ tranh thủ vài phút vài phút thật sự
được mặt cha là
ừ giờ này miếu chưa xem đâu chưa hết đâu
anh chính chủ tâm sự một tí
nhớ thay đổi mờ nóng xem được khác mỉm
cười
vẫn lỗi này
à à
Cho tôi xem ảnh trên điện thoại xem được
mà
nó dễ thờ kiểu à
ừ ừ
cho Android không được
Em xem trên điện thoại tôi xem được thì
cảm ở phường trình duyệt điện thoại luôn
xe hơi kỳ lạ về thằn view này
ở công viên Facebook gỗ Xem không Xem đồ
chơi nào ạ Mở máy tính
ừ ừ
Anh
không biết là các bạn chơi game này có
biết khái niệm về kẻo chí chưa chết nếu
một dịch xa nó sẽ là kiểu gian lận nó sẽ
đôi khi khái niệm kiểu chích trong game
thì nó sẽ hiểu là khách khủng cái thứ
cầu dạng nhà
Ừ nó nó kiểu dạng là kiểu à Ồ
hát Nói chung là làm cách nào để thắng
Dễ Hay gì khiến nó game mà dễ hơn đấy
thì khái niệm khi cuộc sống như như tôi
đã định nói thì nó Nếu giả sử Nếu giả sử
cuộc sống của mình cũng sống như là đang
chơi game này ạ thì
em đi cày cá nhân cá nhân tôi từng chơi
không biết các bạn như thế nào nhưng
chắc trả lời tôi từ chối hack Tưởng chưa
chích các thứ thứ
cho các bạn nếu sử các bạn Bi trí
biết kiểu các mã để mở kiểu tiền nó chơi
game mà dễ hơn không phải cả phần mềm
hack mà là kiểu dáng
đôi khi giống cái liên tưởng nhất là
dùng kiểu chơi GTA đấy ạ là game mô
phỏng kiểu lá lá kiểu dạng là mình file
vào một người ở đó xong rồi đi làm nhiệm
vụ xong rồi Kiểu kiểu cũng gần như trong
cơ thể hai người cũng khá giống cuộc
sống ngoài đời có rất nhiều cái kiểu
công việc hay đủ mọi thứ mình phải làm
đủ thứ để kiếm tiền hay gì đó Cái đôi
khi chúng ta thích kiểu muốn trở nên bá
đạo mình muốn kiểu trở lên thì nó game
mà dễ hơn đỡ phải mùi cài thì mình sẽ
hiểu chạy những cái đoạn Mã để mà à
anh cái mã đấy thì Xuka à chính cả
hãng nó cũng công khai chứ không phải là
kiểu dạng là thì mình khách của nó những
đại khái là như thế kiểu dạng khiến cho
việc trải nghiệm game nó sẽ dễ dàng hơn
thì đương nhiên là tôi từng làm thế và
tôi trở ra nhiều lúc làm thế kiểu để cho
vui rồi giết thời gian cái hướng thì
anh không biết các bạn đã từng chip kiểu
như thế chưa nhưng nhưng
Ừ nếu mà Giả sử Trong cuộc sống nó có
cái thứ hè nó mọi thứ dễ dàng hơn như
thế kiểu Tôi đã từng Nhiều lúc tôi
thường nghĩ dụ ví dụ nha chỉ đơn giản là
kiểu
Giả sử mình sinh ra là một tỷ phú hoặc
con chắc chắn là con tỷ phú sinh tự
nhiên kiếm được đâu con tỷ phú con tỷ
phú Việt Nam Đồng còn tỷ phú đôla con
còn triệu phú và văn thì thì mình sẽ như
thế nào
em chẳng hạn thế
Ừ nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là cái tỷ lệ các tỷ
lệ để mà để bảo tối theo ngày này hoặc
là để tôi kiểu dạng là làm gì làm vì
cộng đồng như bây giờ ấy thì lại mà khi
mà tôi đã thành tỷ phú Huế hội khác nhau
Ừ thôi nghĩa tớ sẽ trở thành con người
khác hoàn toàn sẽ không phải là con
người kiểu vì cộng đồng như giờ bởi vì à
Có rất nhiều yếu tố và chỉ cho tôi kiểu
dạng là muốn làm những cái điều như bây
giờ đang làm một trong những yếu tố quan
trọng nhất đó là tôi không muốn ai cũng
từng bị như mình đã từng kiểu ở là kiểu
cầu dạng mà cầu và tôi muốn mọi người
cũng kiểu được tôi Tôi từng nói Tôi rất
là may mắn khi mà được gặp được vài
người giúp đỡ nhưng mà thời gian để mà
học hỏi mọi thứ thì nó vẫn rất mất thời
gian và muốn tốn kém may mà mình may mắn
được như thế Mọi thứ nó cũng được gọi
suôn sẻ nhưng không phải Hạt được như
thế này ra là tôi Cậu muốn hỗ trợ phần
nào đấy
thế hệ tôi từng cảm thấy rồi bế tắc ở
trong trong cuộc sống chứ phải trong mỗi
ngày nghề này Nói chung là như thế thì
Ừ nếu mà mày nói chung là tôi đang nói
với cái khía cạnh nó rộng hơn không phải
mỗi học tập Luôn nhá mà tôi em nói câu
nếu mà Mấy ông gặp tôi ngoài đời thì ông
sẽ thấy các cậu tôi
tôi vẫn khẳng định tôi là một con người
mà gọi là bạn bè tốt à Kiểu cái thế bởi
vì a cậu khi giả sử là bạn bè khi mình
đi chơi tôi thì sẽ rất thoải mái được
khoản là
tôi nói chung là tôi cố hết sức tốt với
bạn bè nó thứ đấy thì không phải không
phải mỗi việc là chơi được nhé Tôi là
người đã chịu chơi nhưng mà nói
mình tốt thật chứ không phải được lệnh
sau lưng là gì cả và Vân là như thế thì
Ừ nếu mà giả sử mà cuộc sống của tôi nó
nó được gọi là êm đềm hơn ấy chứ thằng
tôi không trở thành con người nuôi rồi
nhà tôi cảm thấy là tôi về cơ bản thì do
là mình thì da mình nói mồm với đôi mình
không hiểu không có cuộc sống như kia
nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy tôi vẫn an trân
trọng cuộc sống thôi dù nó không hề êm
đềm chợ nào tả
nhé Thì
ạ và Nếu giả sử Cho Dù bây giờ số có cái
để mà chít kiểu như thế cái dụ là sửa
trí để đô thị trong game đôi khi không
cần phải cái gì ở rất là ghê gớm không
phải kiểu biến mình thành sự bá đạo đôi
khi chính trong game đôi khi ở chị ấy
làm cho mình tiền rồi ạ thường là nếu mà
trong GTA V ở trong hạn mình kiểu một
con số tin rõ khùng 2 triệu đâu hả 10
triệu đô gì đấy Không nhớ cho Nếu giả sử
mà được như thế Giả sử Nếu mà được cả
một cục tiền đưa xuống Văn thì tôi vẫn
sẽ không muốn
lại thế nè các bạn sẽ biết được tôi khá
trê khoản để tôi không nghĩ của chất này
đương nhiên là mình không chê tiền nhưng
mà nó nói là không muốn cuộc sống nó kêu
dễ dàng theo kiểu như thế mọi thứ tôi
vẫn muốn tự mình cố gắng để kiếm nó được
cố gắng để mà đạt được nó
cho ví dụ Giả sử bây giờ bạn tự nhiên
được phát cho mình lên cái chức vụ gì đó
Giám Đốc hay gì đó tôi cũng không muốn
muốn tự mình hết tự mình đạt được thì
cảm giác cảm giác khi mà đạt được một
cái gì đó trong cuộc sống mà khi mình
rất là cố gắng mới đạt được không ạ thì
mình mới trân trọng thương sự mình mới
trân trọng nó con nếu mà kiểu dạng là tự
nhiên ông có được sự ấu không trân trọng
lắm đúng không ạ Cái này tôi nghĩa là
cái này thì nhà văn vở ở Huế nhưng mà
nhiều người thì nhớ lúc người ta kiểu
kiểu thấy chán nản trong cuộc sống quá
đi người bạn muốn cuộc sống họ dễ dàng
hơn trên làn rồi nhưng mà tôi thì à
Ừ tôi thì có những cái thử cả tôi nghĩ à
anh ở tôi chẳng muốn có một cái điều ước
gì cả ra như thế
ở chặng nhiều người sẽ đổ nước rất nhiều
thứ có trước nhiều người hối trước tôi
từng mơ mộng thôi mùa nước nhiều thứ
nhưng cho đến thời điểm hiện tại sau rất
nhiều thời gian cố gắng nhưng tôi cảm
thấy à Ở
là ừ ra mình đang hài lòng với cuộc sống
hiện tại
em không cần phải ước một cái gì cả
Ừ nếu mà như thế thì nó sẽ rất là tốt
theo kiểu là nếu ông không bất mãn cuộc
sống hay gì cả Không chấp nhận và phấn
đấu thì nó sẽ hơn không ạ Hay vì mấy ông
cưng ngồi trông chờ một cái điều ước một
phép màu xảy ra nhưng Tự dặn tạo ra cái
mới thôi
khác thì tôi đi ừ
Ê mày Tôi sẽ chỉ cho mấy ông về một vài
cái
tranh thủ là chữa bài 13 hôm trước thì
ra tôi không nhớ được là mình đang làm
dở Cái gì cơ rồi
đau không động vào quên sứ hết rồi
tải Facebook lỗi à
rồi nhỉ Mình cần khi tơ thêm một vài cái
chuông nữa không ạ Nhưng mà trước đấy
tôi xin phép à
sẽ
thì mình sẽ trả lời tất cả câu hỏi từ
những cái lần trước đi
đầu tiên thì tôi nhớ không lầm là có bạn
lần trước gợi ý về cái thai thùng mình
sẽ dùng cái À à
cách để mình làm thay đồ và dịch phân xử
đúng rồi
only này Office Cẩm Ly hybris ngoan thì
lần trước tôi muốn là viết hoa có chữ
rồi chữ O và hai cái này là là dấu gạch
dưới ấy thì hôm trước có bạn bảo là chỉ
cần nói chỉ cần là
Em đổi cái này thành đổi cái này thành
kiểu dấu cách sau đó đi à
ạ sau đó thì cậu à
ở Đồng la viết thường viết hoa mỗi chữ
cái đầu từ cái là được Hay vì kiểu Tôi
làm kiểu như này
Anh không dùng Trinh Thay đổi là được
thế thử nha à
tôi thay bồ remote thành phố Lima review
Ừ cái này dùng ở đâu nhỉ À
biết được mà mình dùng cái đấy đâu nhỉ
remote
ở đây đây đây sau
sẽ thay cái này bằng cách là đấy là kiểu
này mình đội nó thành nhà
thì
mình sẽ
là kia cả ngày Nếu mà kiểu như này
Ừ thì nó sẽ là Office for lease nhớ ai
mà không thấy không ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ
thay Nó là kiểu sinh play này
thì mình sẽ đổi nó gạch dưới hàng gấu
cách như thế này
Kinh ai
đó
nó chưa Cố tình sẽ ngắn hơn đấy Tôi vừa
trả lời được cái à trình lại thay đồ rồi
ok Rồi tiếp theo
ở chỗ tối ưu Cốt lại là nếu mà ông xe mà
không hiểu thì à gạo hơi khó nghe là
thỉnh thoảng tôi sẽ tối ưu Cốt lại cho
miếng Xem
tiếp theo về cái vụ web này thì à
mình phải kiểm tra rất kỹ tránh việc à
Nó nó chuyển vào cái ta tinh
ở nhà Tôi sẽ tạo một cái à
tử vi quét ở đây đi
thứ nhất đó là mấy ông phải kiểm tra kỹ
việc là người ta chị không được phép
truyền ở linh tinh nhưng
thế nhưng nó lại có một cái đó là mấy
ông không nên chuyển trả về trả về báo
lỗi cho người dùng
ở đây đây tí tôi nó như này
ờ ờ
City cả ngày không ạ nó làm ảnh mà không
ạ truyền lên là giả mạc đúng chứ
anh chưa lãng mạn đúng không Nhung
truyền lên là cái gì đó Truyền đây là
dạng chuỗi hạch Vân
Ừ thì thì nó sẽ bị lỗi ngày tôi thử giả
sử truyền Gặp chỗ này
thì đưa ra ông sẽ phải phạt viridis
truyền lên rồi Chắc chắn rồi nhưng mà
Mấy ông không nên trả về cái Trang đấy
cầu thủ làm luôn miếu cho mình cũng
giống ở
à à
à
à make request này mình sẽ có đây là áp
Nichkhun nhưng mà Cho xem à Chắc ngày
thực ra là Trang hôm đấy phu của mình
trước vài cân
em xem giá xem nhạc remix
nó trong african I come back
Ừ thôi kệ đi vậy Thế mình sẽ có IP cân
không Tết
chèo Index quét nha tên nó càng dài
nhưng mà vì sau sẽ càng càng hiểu chưa
nhỏ nhỏ ra em không nên tiết kiệm mà cái
vụ này
biết chồng ăn Min cũng được xử thế
à à
anh ở đây thì mình sẽ sửa lại không ạ Nó
là Intex vì quét
Ừ
[âm nhạc]
rồi đấy thì ở đây cái khái niệm A ngoài
này thì thứ nhất là tôi Ờ thôi tôi cho
mấy ông xem lại kể cài di quét cũng sẽ
thấy nha ai ở đây tôi toàn Xin chào phải
là Chu Tước là sao nghĩa là mặc định cho
nó hiển nhiên là đúng không ạ thì thực
ra cái này là sai thì cái Bởi vì lần Đấy
lần này tôi chưa làm được cái vụ đăng
nhập nhưng tôi vẫn phải làm thế này con
chuẩn ra mình sẽ phải kiểm tra xem là
người dùng đấy có đăng nhập hay chưa thì
mình sẽ thường hay kiểu đau như này
xong rồi à trách để kiểm tra nha chị ạ
ngay Chẳng hại nhưng ở đấy với điều kiện
ở ông muốn kiểm tra
em kiểm tra người đã đăng nhập hãy chưa
mỗi khi vào mày cái quét như thế này
Thực tế thì tôi đang thấy thì có lúc cái
này nó đúng có lúc này nó sai tại sao nó
lại say Bởi vì bởi vì nó hơi bị buồn
cười một điểm đó là cái này đúng là nó
đứng con là vấn đề về bảo mật có nhưng
mà nó bị mừng cười điểm Đó là ví dụ nha
Cái cái sau đi quét này được dùng ở
Company controller Đúng chứ Đúng chứ ai
để lưu lại Company đúng không Ok
Ờ Ờ nhưng mà cái cancel này lại được
dùng ở bên router admin Tại thấy không ạ
Đây như thế này mà lưu lại đúng ạ thì
mặc định router admin này rồi thì mình
lại kiểm tra một lần nữa phải cao dồi
ngân hàng ra à khi mà vào đây quét này
nó kiểm tra thêm một phát nữa đứng yên ở
thực ra kiểm tra thế kiểu lấy từ sĩ sinh
ra thì cũng nhanh thôi nhưng ý rô là nó
hơi bị về thiếu mặt về mặt lôgic một tí
nữa là sao nghĩa là ông ông để cái admin
ở controller kiểm tra
em kiểm tra Chung
chị à là ông kiểm tra kiểm tra cái này ở
trong ở trong cái miss the well rồi
nhưng ở bên này ông lại kiểm tra một lần
nữa Và đôi khi là và đôi khi là kiểu cần
biết được quê của ông còn kiểm tra thêm
nhiều điều kiện lịch sử ít amin nhận Nếu
nhớ không ạ thế này cái hàm của tôi để
mà lấy kiểu để mà lấy cụ thể out và kết
hợp việc là lấy zô chẳng hạn xử thế
nói là thứ nhất là ngoài giờ còn nó bị
kiểm tra lặp lại thứ hai nó có thể khác
với cái mình kiểm tra ở bên middleware
ra sửa midway mình kiểm tra thêm nhiều
điều kiện nữa kiểm tra nếu phải admin
không Rồi và Vân thì nó còn khác so với
kiểu
ý tôi là như thế nghĩa à bên kia kiểm
tra một kiểu bên này kiểm tra một kiểu
khi nó không còn đúng nữa đúng chứ Thì
thế nên là tôi không ngờ Cai Thừa Nhớ
cái một cái giữa hai mí tôi là
tao nó chưa có mặt thống nhất về việc
kiểm tra ví dụ Giả sử Giả sử nhá là kiểm
tra kia rồi có thể bỏ qua đây hoặc kiểm
tra ở kia như thế nào Cái ở đây nó sẽ
thử hưởng kế thừa lại cái ở kia thì nó
nóng tiện mà nó xịn hơn nhưng mà hình
như chưa chưa làm vụ đấy hình như tôi
tôi biết đến thời điểm hiện tại chưa Nếu
mà Mấy ông biết rồi thì chỉ thôi nhưng
mà về cá nhân tôi biết thì chưa có vụ
đấy nghĩa là mít the way mình kiểm tra
kiểm tra nếu nó amin Hải Vân còn ở bên
này lại bị lại kiểm tra lại thì nó thành
kiểu người ông bị bộ lọc lại code là một
thứ hai đó là
ở đó là giả sử bên kiểm tra mục tiêu bên
này kiểm tra một kiểu thiếu hay ngay
trong buồn cười nó hiểu rõ ông ạ
cho nó hiểu rồi đúng không Này thì Thì ý
tôi là như thế chứ tôi không nói về cái
này đưa như cái này à bà nên là phải có
kiểm tra nên có kiểm tra Giả sử giả sử
như trong trường hợp mà tôi đang định
bảo đây Nếu giả sử Nếu mà ở trang home
page và cái Trang mà không cần đăng nhập
vẫn thể xem được tất cả bài đăng ký cho
da mình không cần kiểm tra gì cả Đấy là
xưởng mình sẽ cho luôn là truy cản để đỡ
phải kiểm tra có lúc thì cần gửi kiểm
tra có lúc gì không Cái đấy tác dụng của
cái này Nhưng mà khi kiểm tra thì tôi
muốn là thử hưởng của cái thằng midway
trước đấy chứ không cần phải là chữ mình
ghi vào trong này Thứ nhất là mình gặp
lại cốt là kiểm tra một phát nữa thứ hai
ở đôi khi nó sẽ kiểu Nếu Ok thì bây giờ
giả sử là bê tôi để nói ít pin để cho
giống bên ít midway không ạ tự nhiên về
sau bên middleware của tôi là sửa lại
tôi phải kiểm tra thêm một vài điều kiện
nữa thì thành A toàn bộ những cái quét
cũ ở trong cái midway này
Ừ anh ăn nói lại say vì nó kiểu nó bị nó
bị mất cái lôgic mà lúc đầu mình làm đó
là
ở đó là sao Mà cái lôgic mà hồi đầu tôi
dậy các bạn về mpc về Facebook nếu không
nhớ gì không ạ Chúng ta chỉ cần sửa ở
một chỗ tất cả chỗ khác vẫn phải chạy
bởi vì nó đồng bộ với nhau để ông ạ Còn
trong trường hợp này tôi đang thấy nó
không đồng bộ vì nhau không ạ thế này
Đấy do mấy ông hiểu được Lý do tại sao
tôi phải tạo ra mới hàm là admin thế này
để tôi kiểm tra mọi chỗ chứ nếu mà tôi
mà không tạo cái Hà như thế này thì khi
mà khi và kiểu Giả sử là như tô vừa ghi
nhiều người ghi và chính công ty tôi
cũng đang bị cái tình trạng này
tôi ghi là kiểu chỉ kiểm tra chung chung
là kiểu là người dùng của đăng nhập thì
thôi Nếu mà thực tế là mấy ông vừa thấy
ở bên Mỹ được quay nhá Bin Bin the way
của thằng thằng này như tôi vào bảo
thằng này ở bên admin đúng không ạ Biết
the web của thằng admin này Ừ thì nó lại
kiểm tra thêm một vài cái nữa nó kiểm
tra admin mới được em như thế này cơ
đúng chứ đúng không
Em ngủ dậy chưa
ạ
Bây giờ mình sẽ phải bây giờ mình sẽ
thay vì cái đoạn này thì mình sẽ lại ít
admin ngay
không ạ ấy như này và ở bên toàn bộ
những cái request này mình sẽ là
I eat smim the web
ở hoặc để mọi chỗ khác ngọn chỗ khác
Bình Mình chỉ cần cập nhật ở Xiaomi là
sau nhưng mà nó lại sinh ra một cái như
tôi vào nó vẫn không bất nó vẫn không
đồng bộ thức ra sao thì những clip quét
cũ của tôi đã làm ở trong cái thằng
thằng ăn lên rồi tốt là phải sửa lại đây
dù là sự là Porsche này
ở đây Thằng này mày thì sao
cái post đăng bài khi nó con nó nói chỉ
cần kiểm tra đang đã đăng nhập là được
bởi vì thằng này lại liên quan bà tổ lại
liên quan Mai toán này cả
hát rồi cũng thể đang được bày cả người
dùng thì đang được bày ra xử hết đấy thì
nó nó sẽ kiểm tra kiểu Âu a check thì
được chỉ cần là người dùng đăng nhập
được
Ừ đúng rồi Cái này thì ra mà chia nhỏ ra
này nửa cái hai nửa cái do nó là bất
đồng bộ nó không kế thừa được cái thằng
biết là QS do như thế thì nhờ Company là
hydro vẫn cũng đang được thì phải
Ừ ừ thế thì nói chuyện làm sao ơi sao
thì tôi sẽ để nó Urê thôi được thì phải
ạ
housal
lấy thế để kéo Wendy
an toàn bộ những cái này sẽ sửa lại
icheck này
Ừ
đấy nó cái sự rồi Nếu mà xử tôi đã tạo
hàng trăm người quét rồi Bây giờ người
sửa lại trăm chỗ
thì nó sẽ rất là Cậu lằng nhằng ở đoạn
đấy
bảo thì thôi quay lại bài toán ở đây thì
nó phải nó dễ hơn mà mọi việc mặc định
là trang chủ của mình vào không cần đăng
nhập vẫn để xem được tất cả bài đăng nên
không cần phải kiểm tra là đăng nghiệp
gì cả
khi
của tôi chia sẻ cho mấy ông nó là cái
kiến thức cơ
ý kiến thức kiểu cho tôi tự tôi tự đúc
kết về thực sự thì tao leo này với các
bạn thì mấy ông thấy đấy tài liệu của nó
không phải tài liệu nó không chuẩn và
tài liệu của nó nó vẫn có cái gì đó khó
đọc khó hiểu
bởi vì nó rất là rộng và và vẫn còn chưa
đủ tài liệu nó thẳng định ở vẫn chưa đủ
anh Bởi vì có rất nhiều cái nó khó giải
thích nó không đề cập mà hoặc là nó ít
dùng không đề cập vào trong cái ta liệu
api này của nó mới thực sự là đủ mà
tại điều này thì bị ông Thế còn giới
khủng nữa để nó toàn bộ file code của
cái thư viện nagell đấy thì thế nên là
có rất nhiều cái Có thể tôi chưa biết
hòa thuận chứ Tôi say có nên là đây là
gần như ở đây là là mấy ông thấy có cái
gì đó mà Mấy ông thấy không hợp lý mà
không thấy sai mấy ông cứ phải góp ý
giống như ngay cái vừa rồi Tôi vừa sửa ạ
thì tôi vừa có hôm trước có bạn bảo là
làm theo cực hay hồ kiểu như tôi vừa sửa
thì nó nhanh hơn ngoại thì tôi cứ nhiệm
tôi sửa luôn không nhớ tên bạn đấy lắm
đấy tao vừa sửa lại Nó hàng như này
trong cốt nó ngắn gọn hơn cho cốt trước
nó dài hoặc không thể kéo dài hơn để xử
lý thì có đoạn này chỉ đơn giản là kiểu
xoạc thay thế nó xong rồi đổi có hàng để
đổi lại nó xong Anh
anh nói chung là mấy ông có đóng góp Và
tôi thấy ở cái nào phù hợp cái này về cơ
bản thì tôi đang chia sẻ cộng đồng mà
Mấy ông thấy đó là mấy ông cũng muốn
chia sẻ thì mới ông cũng cùng đóng góp
với cộng đồng với tôi không ạ Không
không sao cả Em chưa Công nghệ thông tin
Bách Khoa rồi buồn quá
Anh ở thử ca gì à
anh không biết ở nói thế này thì nó ông
tích cực hơn không Nhưng mà thực tế thì
À
tôi không khẳng định là à tôi vẫn khẳng
định Bách Khoa vẫn nằm trong top những
cái trường tốt đúng không Nhưng nhưng để
là quan thì thực tế là những cái trứng
tốt như thế thành ra thì khi mà vào học
có rất nhiều áp lực áp lực từ việc học
áp lực từ việc gia đình theo mình vào
cái trường đấy rồi mình học kém hay do
tệ gì đó kết hợp cho cả mình phải chạy
đua về những cái thằng mà Tôm Khi Thảo
trường đấy Nghĩa Đồng Nghĩa nó khá giỏi
và vân kết hợp được cả là nói chung là
nó áp lực và lúc đi học thì gần như lúc
nào cũng dễ ghép được lấy vào
khiến cho nó căng thẳng hơn và học vọng
sẽ khó
cho nên thực sự thì
Ẩm Thực sự thì
tôi không là tôi nói Thấy không phải là
khuyên mấy ông là không không nên về
cách khoan vào nói là ờ là học chọn một
môi trường Thì ông nên chú trọng quan
trọng nhất đấy không phải là kiến thức
mà là thầy cô có thể dạy cách dạy của họ
phải ổn hay không Họ truyền được Cảm
Hứng Ông không hãy nên nhở và bìa ở
ngành Công nghệ thông tin thì thôi Không
biết hàng khác nhà
Em tự học vẫn là nhiều nhất chứ không
phải bất kì thầy cô nào thể dạy đủ cái
nước cho câu đến chính là tháng tôi Tôi
không phải dậy rồi ơi dồi kiến thức là
tất cả ông đúng không ạ Vẫn chủ yếu vẫn
là tự học đúng ạ Thì người nào truyền
được cảm hứng cái môi trường 22 là thậm
chí thậm chí giống như ôtô trước ạ Nếu
giả sử tôi vào cái trường cũ của Học
viện Bưu chính Viễn thông được sử thầy
cô rất tốt nhưng mà việc tôi đi từ nhà
đến trường rồi mấy cây tôi cũng sẽ lười
đi đoạn mà lời lời đi học là giỏi rồi
không ạ này rất nhiều yếu tố khiến cho
kiểu ông theo được theo được lớp hay
không có vần ông mà không theo gót ông
cũng sẽ nào đúng không ạ cho tất cả các
bạn khác giỏi ông rốt ông cũng sẽ là rất
nhiều yếu tố thì
Ừ cái môi trường học hay mọi thứ mới là
yếu tố quan trọng khi mà chọn trường đại
học chứ không phải là trường đấy rất là
tốp giỏi Hải Vân Vân là mấy ông nên vào
tôi không khuyên với ông hẳn là nên vào
những cái trường tốt đến như là mấy ông
cực kỳ giỏi chỉ ra không ngồi đây như
thuốc phiện Đâu đúng ạ mà gần như là mấy
ông sẽ tầm trung bình đổ lên chẳng hạn
hay gì đó phân vân thì thì
em cũng chỉ nên chọn trường tầm vợ là
khá rồi đấy cận thế
Ừ chứ chưa Nếu thực sự thì mấy ông mà cứ
ham vào cái trường tốp kiểu các thứ Huế
có chìa ông sẽ rất bị ăn được rất nhiều
thứ
em thật sự tôi cảm thấy đấy gần nhiều
rất nhiều người từ sẽ phải thế mà Đó là
kiểu học với chúng tốt đấy Cả ngày nào
như sắp đang thi đại học cũng đúng rồi
như thế
cho nên là
Ừ nè Tôi nghĩa với ông đừng đặt nặng quá
dược vào đại học bây giờ
nữa Bằng cái ở gần như bị đại cháy hết
rồi tôi quen đời ông mát đại học Bách
Khoa bằng khá giỏi có những thứ gọi là
thân nghiệp việc ông không làm được việc
thì người lạ không bao tiền không ông
đừng lấy cái bằng lời khỏe Khi cả ông đi
du học mang cái bằng hết chiết hạt cái
thạc sĩ ở bên nước ngoài mẹ ngoài hơn
với Khoa đúng không mang về vẫn không
tuyển được bởi vì bởi vì a trong đâu lý
thuyết nhiều quá trong ngành này thực tế
kiểu cần thứ hai ông chẳng hạn vẫn không
vào được với ông kia này chẳng kiện của
đài ông khai bằng với à à
Ừ lúc đấy người ta có khi người ta sẽ
còn nhìn lâu ngày mắt được mà tiền vào
cái bằng cái gợi Hà giống như kiểu như
tôi không có bằng cái thằng chết rồi cái
gì
tự nhiên mạnh mà cái bằng số không làm
được thì người ta chơi được từ Bách Khoa
thế nào ông nghe cái đấy con còn buồn
hơn
chẳng biết chơi thì hậu cùng nó cũng chỉ
chê rằng ba cái hàng học trường nghề
ở đây Đúng rồi các bạn bị áp lực nữa là
kiểu vào đại học đôi khi đôi khi là
không ảnh thực sự mình muốn vào trường
đấy bởi vì gia đình của muốn mình vào
trong đấy và anh nghe một các bạn rằng
từng Đỗ và thận thì anh em các bạn không
nổ nên ông càng phải vào chẳng gần đấy
thì thì ông đã bị vô hình chung là kẻ
làm cái thứ mà thực ra mình không muốn
gì cả nhưng mà cứ phải là không ạ Nghe
Lâm bị ngay từ lúc đầu ông mục đích của
ông sai rồi đúng không ạ
Ừ chứ nếu mà ông vào như thế thì ông bị
áp lực Đổi thử áp cho ông không được
phép kiểu học lại một môn nào đó cho dù
cái thời sinh viên đại học đấy học lại
môn quá bình thường có rất nhiều lý do
học lại tới khi mình ngủ quá nửa số tiếp
bị chưa thể nào
ấy ông cái cái việc học phải học nó chỉ
là cái bước đầu tiên của ông bước vào
đời thôi để ông đối mặt với sự thật đó
là áp lực có thể đến từ mọi phía và từ
chính gia đình ông có đấy Khi máu vượt
qua là những cái đấy thì ông thì ông lúc
mà ông ra ngoài đại học thì cuộc đời đập
vào mặt ông nhiều áp lực hơn thì không
cần tải được đấy Đây là một trong những
áp lực đầu tiên của
ở ngoài đời đấy ngoài đời nó sẽ không
mộng mơ không thấy gửi thôi
cho mình còn buồn hơn
kệ đi
cậu chia nó một nửa như này
Ỷ Thiên Long có lửa nhà cho tôi
thế này thì chưa có thể
em khỏi Speed Drive và nó kiểu gì
xe Open write speeds
anh Alo Có ai này
ở đây
Ừ tôi sẽ thường ghi cậu ngay nhìn cho nó
kêu mình dễ hiểu
đây này cái
[âm nhạc]
ngu label Hình như có thể được phép để
chống Vậy để tôi nhớ thì tôi xem lại
phát
khi thoa cứ phải xem lại ở sắc
có những cái mình tra được mình không
cần phải nhớ được thả thế thôi Ờ
kennt sao
cha mẹ có thể để chồng ấy
à à
mà Kiều Phong đỡ phải cần kiểm tra những
cái sau mà mà cậu
nó sẽ dừng Ngay khi mà có một cái gì đó
sai này cũng hay
gì thôi
Ừ bắt buộc phải điền à à bắt buộc phải
điền đi qua được nha bây giờ bắt buộc
phải có giá trị nhé
không có
kiểm tra
em có thể lấy chồng đâu nó bỏ qua đi Ờ
thế hào nữa là
Ê hồi nãy có gì đấy xịt mãi
gợi ý thêm nhé
à à
anh không nói gợi ý ban đầu lại mua mắc
không biết được sự thế nào mắt ở
em mất bao nhiêu cũng được mà qua
Anh ở Min không cũng hợp lý mà
à mà không học
xem nha à
thưa cái này tôi không quan tâm để mi
Mac lắm người dùng nhập thế nào được có
quan trọng không có chọn mình à Mình chỉ
cần kiểm tra đơn giản thôi người dùng
nhập sai thì nó trả về kết quả gì đấy
lỗi người dùng không quan tâm nhiều lắm
à
em chỉ chỉ miễn là nó nhập đúng kiểu
kiểu định dạng là đủ
ô tô xe máy
khi tôi thích vứt hết toàn bộ hiểu ý
quét ở lên trên như thế này để bể cho
ở
chỗ cả nhà để mình khi về sau mình nhà
mới hiểu được à À có những cái biến nào
sẽ tồn tại nó sẽ sinh ra để mình làm cái
quét nó dễ Tôi sẽ rất lên như thế
bóng đèn led Blue
À mà tôi thích Tôi thích kiểu như này
thôi ở đây tôi sẽ là du cả ngày à
Ừ chứ thay vì viết như kiểu rồi nối
chuỗi rồi có employed tao không thích
lắm
thôi chứ không phải là chấm thì phải tôi
không thích kiểu đấy
ông sẽ thấy là khi mà tôi để như này ở
nhà City thì tôi vẫn là chuỗi chứ không
phải là mạc nóng lạnh chạy vào thì bây
giờ nó sẽ lỗi sẽ báo về một cái cậu báo
lỗi
có gì
các bác có gì là sai đấy
thể tích thự hà nội nha chạy đi Hà Nội
Hồ Chí Minh này
cho nó điều hướng quay lại em ạ
Đợi thì đợi tôi một tí
chị xem Tại sao xa nha à
anh không
ở mí mắt đấy
ở chung giáp bình thường à
mà tại sao có cái remote Apple đâu nhỉ
a a dimmable đề không à Rồi rồi thì tôi
sẽ thêm một cái đây là vô ngã
đây sẽ kiểm tra không ấy
Ừ nhưng mà nếu thế khi mà mình dùng nó ở
trong những cái á trường hợp
Ninh Bình tĩnh bình tĩnh nha à
a public
Ừ nếu mà bạn dùng trong những cái trường
hợp khác
đù nhanh trường hợp kéo phim Peter như
này không nói
AE nhập nào nhỉ vậy í
trong vụ này thôi ý tôi thì tôi ở đây
nhá đó là tôi chưa làm cái vụ Boss
ô tô request
a remote Thay bồ thôi rồi đây
ở lại là ra à
À mà thôi khó hiểu tại sao bạn này mình
để nó ở đây nhỉ
ừ ừ
tôi lâu không làm quen Xứ Huế rồi lỗi
tôi nói tôi thì được xem lại phát đăng
nhập đi đăng nhập đi
quyền sử Tại sao nói cho biến III rồi
khi đăng nhập tại à
cố lên
à à
xe máy cẩu password ạ
thế này
Khi nào đi thăm vậy ạ
anh hoặc đổi rom được
này thành hạ một chứ là được ok
Ừ để vào b8000 mà
Ừ rồi Ờ
a What's right tạo bài đăng này
ô ô fish à làm thì bọn này đúng không
Mình không làm với mốt con Ly áo phí
only 20 Plus
Ừ ok
để xem à
mình virus rất khó và trong cốt của mình
khi mà xử lý cái đoạn đấy nhớ không lầm
mà mình xử lý cái hồi làm cái bài toán
đấy nó bị khó
số tài khoản kiểm tra như này
anh ở đây còn không có dynamic này bị
sai này không ạ
Cho tôi xin phép sửa lại cả cái đoạn này
nữa để mình sẽ làm bài đấy bạn này
đấy thỉnh thoảng đôi khi review lại cốt
sinh ra nhiều vấn đề Chỉnh sửa một tí
toàn bộ chỗ khác nó bị ảnh hưởng ở
ai bạn Tết này là ngon nhưng có cái đi
mốt rồi
A
part-time thì vẫn thể giữ nguyên của
remote thì tôi sẽ sửa lại nhé sẽ
nó mất ở Đông ạ sẽ sửa lại cái á có
controllo này
sau khi mà mình clip thì mình lấy à
em lấy ra tự mình sẽ lấy à
bộ remote
có bồ
chính tả nữa
Ừ thì ở đây tôi nếu mà giả sử Nếu nó giả
sử mà tôi I nở ra ở trong slakoth chân
kiểu này
nhiều kiểu nhà nha
Hẹn phối nhé
kia bóp chân này
này mình sẽ có nên là remote
Anh buồn ngủ chứ ở đây mình sẽ sửa lại
đây là thứ nhất à Mất p.bồ đi quay này
nó sẽ chị ạ Nó sẽ chỉ nằm trong cái
Ê mày thôi
à à
ba
ngày thôi giá trị của nó sẽ chỉ nằm
trong cái A biết bao lâu rồi thôi
anh alo nét kia rồi à
Đấy nhập
anh alo
em ở nhà cái tôi luôn đúng không đúng
không
Ok Ok
thông tí cái bị ngứa voi ngay phải là
khi đây là
Ê bà lại đúng
cô gái và đấy sẽ Crescent Mall
I fall control a
2 là ờ
vì nó có cái ô này tôi không muốn lấy
cái ô này rõ là mình có remote only
Office only hộp hydrate hai quýt là đủ
rồi mình phải bỏ ghẹo đi ông ạ thì thì
mình sẽ phải làm à
Ừ đấy do tôi không muốn không muốn có về
ô này nằm ở trong cái A có tên này
Ừ tôi muốn là có lúc có một vài lúc sẽ
hiển thị ra thêm kèm theo cái ô còn có
lúc thì không để xem em ạ
ở nhà khoa học Play thì sao nhỉ à
Ê mày biết hình như vẫn lấy ra vì nó
không có cái là nó vẫn đầy ra
Vì thế tôi sẽ phải sửa lại cái đoạn này
đổi nó thành à
thì mình sẽ để nó thành điểm
rất may vết này à
ừ ừ
ô
ô nhà tôi
anh lấy xe lấy à
kiện Halloween with love kina
pete ơ của tôi có cái vụ đầu kia đã
ừ ừ
anh nghe tại sao hiển thị ra được như
thế này chị nhé
Ý em sao
ô tô remote site areas
à à Rồi rồi rồi Ok ok Nó ra như thế Mình
dùng cái Lang lâu lắm không làm quên hết
rồi Ờ
cho Android
cả hai có thể sửa lại dusit
à à
sát thích à
Ừ cái gì nhỉ
chị xem
XIII ê
thế lại phải chơi trò này với ạ
à Không này
cái này em bỏ qua này
ừ ừ
a Quick Shout OD
ca nhạc sống
có ai sẽ là
thì mình sẽ trả về sao Android Nhưng mà
mình sẽ ở đây khóc
này có biết Alipas Tức là nó sẽ là xóa
thằng đầu tiên thì à
tiên Ok ngay
ừ ừ
axit nha nhá mình mới trả về đây được ok
thì nó sẽ thằng ơi ship này sẽ sẽ xóa ở
trong cái mảnh này theo đầu tiên mà mình
sẽ trả thằng đấy chính là xóa Thằng ô ấy
Ừ thôi nha à
Em thử tay trong vòng xe luôn này à
bộ phim sex thú à
also wish sau này sẽ đi tôi không ai
mình cũng sẽ thấy
I was high tech này à
ô không ạ Tôi đây Tôi đang muốn làm thế
nhé Cho một vài trường hợp và tôi sẽ
không muốn lấy xong ô tiền hình nhà Điển
hình như đây này tôi muốn à
kết Ô có sao này này sẽ loại bỏ cái
thằng ô đi đấy
gì để mà nhiều lúc mình sẽ remote ăn
nhiều lúc mà mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ không chọn không không không
cần lấy thằng ô nhưng có lúc mình sẽ lấy
ví dụ như trong trường hợp này trang chủ
của mình như một Apple Tôi đang để ô
chẳng tôi sẽ cần lấy
ờ ờ
mình sẽ lây nhưng thường em nó sẽ không
bị lỗi gì cả
em nói không thể nói chạy được không Và
lỗi thì cả chứ nếu mà tôi giờ rồi Tôi
tắt hay đi rằng ạ Cái
từ giờ sẽ bị điều hướng quay trở lại
đúng không ạ không thể Nó điều hướng
quay trở lại Bởi vì nó không hợp lệ
tỷ lệ khiếu thằng ngu là không gặp bệnh
bởi vì mình vừa rồi mình khi tôi theo
không à
cả hai con bị xóa luôn hai rồi đợi Tí ơi
Tí à
Ê thằng phi tơ này vẫn phải còn mới đúng
xinh nhỉ
a
Battery with Lucky
đây đây đây vẫn vẫn còn vẫn còn ok
à Còn thằng ngu nhé Cái Pad vừa rồi của
nó làm cho nó khôi phục lại thì giao
diện cũ thì ra thằng ôn này vẫn còn Ok
Đọc lại thử xem nha Ừ ok không báo lỗi
gì cả anh thử Xóa Thằng City này tôi đổi
nó thành kiểu ngay nó sẽ chỉ ở city có
mỗi Hà Nội thôi không có
chú chạy này nó không phải ảo đây
Ừ thì nó vừa
Ừ nó vừa Bác Hồ tôi đúng không Nó bác
quay trở lại mày không khéo cái thằng vi
quét này cứ mỗi khi mà nó không chạy
được nó sẽ kiểu J League bác mà nó sẽ
điều hướng quay trở lại
Ừ Ok Thế đồ đấy à
có một Apple rồi còn gì nữa nha à
liên quan đến selfie selfie chạy chạy
tạo máy ảo chạy trên chính máy mình mà
300 liên quan đến mạng rồi
lưu lại cái bài bà này nữa
hôm nay sẽ là remote table không ạ Ừ nếu
có remote Apple thì lấy nó này à
ở isb moddable
khi nghe xong mày à
trò chơi được
nào
tai nghe nhé
à à
không ạ nhanh hơn nhé Đúng mà mình đã
truyền thêm một vài cái giúp là sự lời
Company rồi language Thì thực tế thực tế
là không truyền nó vào vì nó không nằm
trong cái phim babel
từ lúc anh lúc nhảy này ờ
vì tôi nghĩa là bạn này Chỉ cần vài đấy
là đủ rồi
Anh xóa đi chợ xóa bạn anh sửa lại đi
nhanh à
Khi nói đến Tịch ngày mà lấy những cái
đã được vài đứa nữa song không không tầm
phải làm mất công ngay đâu thử thì biết
nhỉ
ở hồ chí minh họa Company này chọn này
này
ở bài thừa chú ếch nó ok ok coi
ở tạm được mà
à a đây đây đây đây đây đây Đúng rồi
mình à
Ừ mình trong trường hợp này thì mình à
wish sao rồi mày
Ừ
cái remote bổ đây tôi cũng phải truyền
kết Miss tao như này
nó thì thì lúc mà hiển thị ra cái pho
mày sẽ không có cái ô nữa Đúng rồi Đúng
coi
ở nhà mày không ai à
A và bắt chước như cái ở bên A
ở bên cái giao diện ở bên
hôm này mình hiển thị mới cái kiểu ngay
cho nó chuẩn nha à
à à
thì tao đây
Ừ anh như này Cơn Lốc Sân của mình sẽ từ
cái kia luôn à Ừ
đi xe từ cái kia
đúng rồi nhỉ
Em ăn Tết trăm ki
anh à hình như tôi đang đến nó là ngôn
ngữ hình như là tiếng nhá chứng gì nhỉ à
nhưng mà nó sẽ phải để phô nó tiếng Anh
ấy nhỉ
Ừ Nói tí nha len của tôi tiếng Anh này
à à fanpage
ăn rắm á
à À rồi
Cái này của tôi biến thành lâu Ký
ơi xin cho Long karaoke
viết hoa để mình được phải làm nghỉ xem
nha thường là mấy cái không nên viết hoa
Ừ vậy thì đúng à
từ lúc mà mình lấy cái à
ô hay như nào nhỉ Đợi tâm lý đã tôi thế
đấy tôi xem lôgic đoạn này lên như nào
nhé Cái này là
Ừ cái này là i5 này mình không có sửa về
nấu giấc nó nhiều được Nó không phải là
mua đồ để mình à sửa được nó cần lấy giá
trị da nó cắn thiệt giá trị của nó
em
31 Online Office only ok Google ok rồi
ừ ừ
em mặc định tôi cá nhân cá nhân mình thì
mình nên tôi nghĩ là nên 7 nên đẩy nó
để tui iPad này nó
cái thứ hai cái thông dụng nhất nhỉ Lúc
đầu tôi để nó là cái một ly như này rồi
đỡ mất rồi nhưng tôi Thực ra tôi vẫn thì
đẩy nó lên trên ngay để cho nó nhìn thị
lên trên cùng sau đó thì Office only như
thế này sau đó đi như thế này
Ừ tự nhiên mình làm lôgic ở hơi bị ngược
lại cái hay Plus này nó về da hoặc
Office Pony thường ai cái trên cầu bình
an là sự ngay à
Ừ bác sĩ ngay đi
và đương nhiên là lưu ông đệ dp của mình
vẫn à theo cái số này nó sẽ không bị ảnh
hưởng gì cả nhà mình vẫn thể sắp xếp lại
cái thứ tự nó
Ừ đúng ạ Nó kiểu thế
Tôi nhớ thành công và chẳng in lại cái
gì cả
con biết cho xin Ok Ok rồi đấy thỉnh
thoảng tôi sẽ mở cái reod bước 3 này lên
trông đúng Xem này cũng sẽ được rồi
thành công này thấy không
Vì sao phong language kiểm tra xem và
ngôn ngữ tồn tại chưa Nhưng nó chưa thì
bắt đâu
có thêm tạo thêm ngôn ngữ ấy ở đâu ra
Ngôn ngữ này mình không cho
Ừ mình không cho nhập về phải tính nhỉ
ngon mình không cho nhập
ừ ừ
ông dùng từ tờ Tôi không biết được theo
hiểm điều cực kỳ tích cực nữa có nghĩa
sẽ theo hướng tiêu cực của nhiều hơn
Ừ Thế đoạn này bởi vì tôi đang vừa làm
cho buổi tối ưu cho ca mấy ông sẽ thấy
hơi bị loạn một tí thôi không nhận được
đấy nhưng mà
ổ cứng
Ừ nhưng mà tôi đang Tố Hữu lạ dần dần
hiểu tôi như vậy dần dần cái cốt Cũ
nghĩa là gần như à cái ông mà khó hiểu
buổi hôm nay là bố thì mấy buổi hôm
trước mày không phải nắm chắc cái buồn
cho tôi cốt như thế nào đã
ờ ờ thì thì mấy ông thấy cô hôm nay nó
tối ưu được như thế nào chứ về cơ bản
mấy cái hôm trước mấy còn chưa hiểu thì
mai tôi yêu là sẽ bị thoáng đúng
ờ ờ ờ
tụi tao này
chuyển từ chi gần hết xanh caro đái thì
như tôi đang bảo cho cả toàn bộ những
cái này toàn bộ tất cả những cái này thì
thực tế là mình lên đẩy nó sang thành
con sang controller à xanh mua đồ thì nó
hợp lý hơn thì sẽ chuyển chuyển thể truy
vấn này xa mình sẽ đặt tên cho nó để
Cho ké luôn lên nhớ ra câu trả lời nó
lên Ít thôi và thằng mua đồ mình sẽ nó
sẽ dài ra gì à Hồi trước là tôi có viết
cái like template bây giờ do ram tối
khủng Thì ra tôi mới dám chạy ở like
Tablet này
Ê mày cầm biết này nó chứa nhiều sẽ rất
nặng không hay lắm
anh bớt lại không giống mày không lại
tục
à cô này mưa dùng cái này Tắt bớt này
Ừ mày viết xong chuẩn bị để lại được anh
Stick phòng chiến cái này không nhớ thì
gõ đâu xóa đi
tất mưa rồi này lập nick rồi mày
tw200 này không dùng máy stop tôi sẽ cho
Mỹ Dung này cho ai này ăn xét gần đây
tội phạm Dùng khá nhiều bạn xét ở trên
công ty Khi nào tôi chỉ Nếu người vụ án
xét sao
Scope nó sẽ nha à Có ai biết cầu truy
vấn ra thì đây sẽ là home back to top
truyền vào cái mình cần truyền vào đây
sẽ à Quý quét
à à
I stop của tôi viết à Đợi tí stop của
tôi thì biết nó bị à
định khi mà ra cốc thì nó sẽ hiển thị ra
đẹp theo format mình mình lỡ tay format
phát nữa Gần như vừa tôi ờ
anh sex lấy toàn bộ dần dần dần vào nhé
tôi đấy Cái này sang bên phải đi này nó
tiền tôi thêm cái vít vào đông
có ai a police Xem clip bao nhiêu này Ok
này
a tiếp theo ngày nữa
cô
ôm hết và
ở lại
khai báo
anh ở đây
biến đợi tôi một tí
thế nào sẽ hơi khác một tí nữa Ờ mình
khai báo biến ở đây ok này được Đợi tôi
tí nhé
Ừ cái này là không động vào cái qua đi
Đây đúng
Ừ cái nào không động với Kali mình sẽ
đầy nó ở xuống dưới phải quay đi để khai
báo giống như thế này
ờ ờ
Em Không Đợi tao đấy xuống dưới này
em ở đâu có có có có
ê kê rồi
an toàn bộ như thế này không ạ
ngày nữa À mà tôi vẫn thường nói qua
trước nhóm nhạc sẽ sửa lại nói anh như
sau ừ
ô tô một tí đợi ông Tý
ý nghĩa sợ lại đồ thích đoạn này ngay
à à
cho tôi thưa đặt tên cái này phi tô nhận
được chị sẽ có một cái à Peter như này
à à
nhầm
đoạn này theo tôi thì nên xử lý như thế
nào nhỉ à
khi khai báo biến như này ok rồi nhé
trước đi
ơi mình có một cái biến Phi tỏ ra đi
khi tờ này bằng này
Ừ nếu mà
chỉ có như này thì mình sẽ có
a City
Anh đang sốt City ngay
[âm nhạc]
Ừ để tránh nhầm với cái gara City đúng
không ạ Về rồi này tiếp
à à
He has Min
ra mẹ ôm về không ạ
anh xe ôm được từ nay về đi
ít nhiều có cái này
Ừ thì mình sẽ có Peter này
à à
anh
ừ ừ
này sau đó thì tôi sẽ chỉ cần à Gọi đến
thằng hopea này
sự thay đổi này bị khi tôi nha
anh không thấy Hà Nội
ờ ờ
Tôi sẽ đặt tên cái này là Index comeback
này
Compact ngay
à à
ừ ừ
truyền vào đây mình quay đi nó sẽ luôn
tự động truyền qua là stop mình sẽ chỉ
lấy ở đây là truyền kỳ Peter này và thôi
nếu không sẽ thấy đó là cái Hà mà nó bị
cảnh báo của kìa khi khai báo stop này
thằng ID của tôi nó sẽ không hiểu được
có là có phải tồn tại nhân thường mà tôi
sẽ kiểu xóa cái comment ở đây này rồi
tôi sẽ chạy cái á
khi tôi viết tắt cái vụ Year mấy ông nhớ
bạn khái niệm với ai hết Bơ này đây
ver.iv hepl chỉ Việt võ ITA xong rồi tên
của cái mua đồ đấy post này sẽ tự động
viết cái comment cho tôi như thế này
hãy comment cho tôi Đặc biệt là thằng
stop họ sẽ tự động viết về thằng sport
vừa rồi
nó báo lỗi
nhá Tiền mày không thấy sẽ không bị báo
lỗi này nữa nó sẽ màu như này không ạ à
tiếp theo
anh ở đây mình sẽ
ạ
sau một bát ngày mình sẽ Return
As I I
a nhớ đương nhiên vừa Mỹ phải sửa lại
một tí ơi mình sẽ không làm theo cậu là
mình sẽ ít chiều ngày nữa mà mà
thì mình sẽ làm là đội bay xong rồi nha
bộ phim sex xnxx
iOS
reset
Peter này
City này
em
làm như nào cho bạn
thế
này phải copy cái đoạn làm đúng
à à
Ừ nếu không sẽ thấy là cái đoạn này
trông nó dài hơn so đoạn này chắc chắn
rồi nhưng mà cái cách xử lý của mình là
controller mình luôn gọi mình sẽ chỉ lấy
những cái J quét ta hiểu ngay
xe tải chiều cao ngay có nhiều chỗ nào
mấy ông ấy quét ra nhưng mà cũng không
hề truyền vào trong thằng này mà đối
ngoại nên là mình sẽ phải phải bảo hết ở
đây như thế này
ăn cơm mình truyền vào trong thằng mua
đồ rồi mua đồ Ôm xử lý rằng ngay mình sẽ
quen thở dài ngay mà tôi nghĩ Return đây
được này tôi không quen mà
thứ hai tôi sẽ lại dần dần nhé
anh access kiểm tra nếu tồn tại này này
a City Xong rồi nhá Anh sẽ có
xe mini
em copy Dạo này
à vì đoạn quà từ qua đây nè
Ừ nó như này
anh xóa tiếp mày
em biết kết đây này
cũng nhanh mà
à à
Yêu
[âm nhạc]
Ê pete ơ
ừ ừ
à à
anh em lỗi gì nhỉ
ê ê
à à
ừ ừ
thì nó sẽ chỉ 2 thôi
à à
I make Sorry lại vào lỗi gì
a ha rồi nhầm nhầm
Ừ ok
ừ nó toàn bộ truy vấn của tôi đã sửa lại
bằng cách ghi hết vào trong nhà à À mua
đồ và bên Angela của tôi sẽ chỉ có là
tôi đè đoạn phải bảo huy quét này
ở đại nowhere vào cái chuối tơ này rồi
ra như này Tại sao có bạn mình sẽ thắc
mắc là tại sao anh lại làm hai cậu làm
như thế này mà không xử lý ở bên mua đồ
thì thực tế
là cái việc controller nó sẽ là xử lý kế
tiếp nhận các request ý Ví dụ ví dụ dạng
như là người cái mô hình một cái xe Tôi
đã từng nói với ông đó là
Ừ cái việc Chế biến chế biến nằm ở đâu ạ
Ê mấy ông nhớ về cái mô hình nhà hàng
không ạ
ở mô hình nhà hàng thì ông là khách hàng
đúng không ạ Ông chỉ ngồi tại bàn đúng
không ạ và nhân viên ở thằng ra thầm
thằng gia để mà nghe món của ông yêu cầu
đúng chưa đúng không ạ
Ừ ông yêu cầu gì thì thì thì nó sẽ tiếp
nhận cái ý kiến của ông Sau đó sẽ đưa
lại cho đầu bếp không ạ Nó cũng là một
bước để mà xử lý từ cái việc thằng thằng
bồi bàn rồi và thằng thằng đầu bếp nó sẽ
khi chế biến thôi Nên là gần như là nó
sẽ gần như nó làm những cái vụ chế biến
ở đây như thế này này này nó sẽ trình
chế biến thôi con
à Còn những cái việc tiếp nhận yêu cầu
Thì đấy là của thằng buổi bạn là đây là
hàng tiếp nhận yêu cầu sẽ xử lý yêu cầu
của ông có những yêu cầu nó sẽ gửi cho
đầu bếp có yêu cầu nó không gửi đầu bếp
nhỏ gọn và đầy đầy cái vụ lọc như thế
đúng sẽ thế là đề cơ bản thì đông nhiên
ở nhìn trong nó phức tạp hơn cho cốt cũ
cả là mấy ông thấy Cốt nó dài hơn nhưng
Ừ nó lại trông nó lại kiểu nó sẽ dễ sửa
hơn chó cốt cũ và khẳng định ở rễ xưởng
con cũ bài toán là dễ xưa quan trọng như
thế
đi theo tôi thêm một cái tô gì đầu tiên
là tôi sẽ sửa trong này cho tôi khai báo
trong này sửa lại đây này xong rồi Bên
này tôi quen thì có nữa là xong gần như
rồi mình sẽ chỉ đăng ký kết đúng kiểu
như này đã ký kết đã ký kết như thế này
có thêm những cái quét thì mình đã ký
kết như này thôi còn bên này tội đã ký
kết như thế này tôi sửa và Và thậm chí
thậm chí nhé về sau về sau khi mà ông
phân công công việc ở trong công ty sẽ
có người làm chuyên về giả sử như trong
trường hợp của tôi là ở công ty hiện tại
em ạ Có nhiều anh em không khẳng định là
Có vài anh em thì không chuyên cơ sở dữ
liệu bằng Tôi có có sự thật như thế bởi
vì một phần là tôi thích về cái cơ sở dữ
liệu nên tôi động mà nhiều đấy Hoa ca
hoa cà da sử là anh em chỉ biết bên mẹ
queo anh em không biết về bên web hay
không biết về cả bé directaccess thế nên
là anh em sẽ chỉ làm controller chỉ làm
cái phân hủy quét là hệ thống truyền vào
truyền vào những cá Ừ cái gì Cái gì còn
về phi tơ về cái xử lý về cơ sở dữ liệu
là bên mua đồ thì tôi là cái chuyện như
thế mấy ông gửi cho tôi đâu nghĩa là
controller mình có thể làm thơ thôi tách
biệt như này tôi xử lý sẽ nằm ở viện này
Ok chứ
Em hãy code nó sẽ trộn tôi đang tôi đang
ở đầy cốt dần từ truy vấn từ controller
sang mua đồ như thế
Phi Nhung heo nó sẽ ngắn hơn Tuần nào
chủ nghĩa ngắn hơn đấy cốt cũ của tôi
phải này bao nhiêu
ở một con trâu này này này lên đầy đủ sẽ
là
db123 không đưa còn 66 dòng nghĩa là
giảm gấp đôi dằm vậy dùng gấp đôi giảm
một nửa số Cốt
à mà xong mới đó là chỉ muốn rút gọn
đúng một hàm rồi đấy Còn nếu mà lịch sử
ông có một đống hàm ở trong các trailer
của ông thì thì nó sẽ nhà nó sẽ rất dài
đúng không ạ đây tôi đã giảm bớt đi và
mấy ông thấy rất là do tôi còn enter
xuống dòng enter cách ra rồi nhìn mọi
thứ cho thoáng là không ạ sử ý mà bên
Nga xử lý với này nha đúng không ạ Đấy
cái đoạn này để mà lấy ra những cái
Peter nữa nha đúng không vì tôm về xử lý
cách tra các ra lối thoát không ạ bên
này như thế nào lấy ra toàn bộ này nhá
order 2 lên đấy luôn đấy Chồng của nhá
như này nha Ok ai mình cái này để were
cho tiện nhé wear thêm vài cái đoạn được
xử lý này thì là cái thích thì ông có
thể đẩy ra Scott nữa cho nhỏ nữa càng
tốt Nếu mấy ông nghĩ rằng mà Chỗ này
dùng ở những chỗ khác được giống như cái
thằng cu này và tôi sẽ dùng ở nhiều chỗ
này tôi sẽ kiểu khai báo passport nữa cô
Peru không ạ Còn nếu mà Mấy ông thấy khi
dùng ở dùng ở mỗi cái á
từ hôm Tết để mà sốt như này Thôi thì
ông chỉ cần dùng ở đây thôi
Khi dòng bàn phím tôi tự nhiên bị kẹt
phím không hiểu
thì sẽ sử dụng đây thôi là tôi thôi Đôi
khi phải thử thực thực tế là đôi khi ở
với ông chưa có chắc thì mày ông phải
copy sang một ít như thế nếu phải test
lại luôn chứ không phải giống như tôi
quê tôi bắt đầu test
Ê mày vẫn chạy
ông ở cậu kéo cốt sang như thế không
chạy lỗi tùm lum chứng thừa không ạ hợp
bơ sửa hoặc là lúc này reverse có
kiểu khôi phục lại công cụ gấp càng
thương sẽ được cái gì
ờ ờ
Ê mày thử gà dạy cũng
em chẳng có dậy thì mới chủ yếu là tôi
anh chủ yếu là tôi Cậu đang ra
khi chọn tối ưu cốt cho bé mà nhiều
không ạ
Ừ để xem không biết được hả
a demo import đôi này
ở hồ que word
our này thì tôi nói với ông rồi quen là
cậu dạng là mình kiểm tra giống kiểu gì
ý ý nếu mà nó đúng thì mình sẽ chạy vào
bên trong này và nhấn mạnh một cái đó là
ông phải luôn Return thì quay còn nếu vợ
ông kiểu khi mà ông ghi thêm thì kewell
rồi như thế này và ông có hình dung là
ông đang đặt thêm cho nó 1 cái gì đó đặt
thêm vào cho nó 1 cái que từ đó tăng cái
Scope mày có bị nhược điểm tôi khó chịu
ở đây tôi không biết là không có đi đây
có gọi được mấy bảo không
bí mật không đấy Cái thứ khiến tôi khó
chịu nhất của Facebook này đó là nếu bây
giờ sử âm như thế này ông quen nha nó sự
thế đúng không ông Ấn vào đấy không xem
được cái hàm của nó thay hỗ trợ cái ông
này gọi Hoàn không ạ
thế nhưng khi mà ông ở bên này bên shop
này này ông không bấm được vào không
click vào được cái cái thứ ông tôi thấy
hơi khó chịu về đôi khi mà quên mất sự
với Hàn này gọi nó ví dụ hấp thu mà
chẳng ăn không bấm được vào nhảy đến Hà
mất luôn đấy Cái nhược điểm đó nó không
biết được à Thằng mỗi học Face tôm bị
thế thằng thằng đi khác có bị thuế không
PS của có bị lại không Nếu không Thứ xe
máy của tôi nha Cái thì thì à
anh nói chung là mày không phải nhớ tất
cả những cái đấy hàm đấy
Ừ nếu mà đi nhậu nhé When Tức là nó sẽ
không trả về cái wed này không đặt thêm
điều kiện không xe lách thêm vài ngày
nữa Chẳng ạ
Ừ thì tố cáo kia đè thêm vào cái truy
vấn quay đi những Phải có ít ơn mà quay
đi đấy thì nó mới truyền thẳng vào thằng
quay góc nhé chứ nếu bảo không đi tơ thì
nó sẽ không giá trị gì đấy ông quen này
nó chẳng có giá trị gì cả nhà nhé với
ông lại thấy à thế cái quay của tôi Tôi
không ghi tên cái quay ở đây là bạn
không biết ơn nha Tại sao bởi vì quen
nói khác Quen như này nói chuyện được
không
ở đâu ạ thế nhưng còn quen thì không
phải đi tôi nhé
phải biết ơn
chị xem nha a worthy Tôm tít rồi nhỉ
ạ
ở đây mình sẽ
mình sẽ ôm trùm cái quen ở đây đi
vợ chồng chứ
Ừ
quay ngay thôi mấy ông sẽ thấy nhé
thì tại sao vậy
ở lại mẫu Hồ Chí Minh á
nó vẫn đi chơn à Tại sao
if
you were nó mới sửa lại rồi
anh không không có đi tơ nó vẫn được rồi
nội thất thế hội mà tôi là bị sai
anh khóc 16 tháng 2 nó bị mất rồi đoạn
này tao quên đấy mời sang trang 2 mình
đã không
chèn thêm cái A
đi kèm thêm cái fito rồi
Ừ ừ thế không cần Nitơ ở đây cũng được
rồi đấy tôi làm tôi nhớ kiểu gì phải đi
trơn cơ
Ừ nếu không cần phải tơ thì tốt cho một
Cốt nó sẽ ngắn hơn tí
ok ok bí quyết này tôi nhớ phải biết ơn
Em có phải cái thứ là cái cái khái niệm
phải get ơn 20 giờ có lúc thì
Ừ ông thích thì nếu bảo không ngờ Chắc
từ giống như tôi thì ông Return nó chắc
họ không ảnh hưởng gì không sai mà lôgic
không chuyển cốt tông chết rồi nếu mà
nếu mà xong ngoài trường hợp nào đó mà
ông
cô gái giống tôi bảo là sử là tự nhiên
nó không nó không phi tơ thì thiệt thôi
ông ạ Thế là nếu không nhớ thì ông cứ
chắc Coffee tơn như là là ổn nhất
quên mất em tư vấn đi bắt bà ở đây được
mà
à Tôi đang Company để tôi đang lấy à
Có ai đi đem logo thôi
thì tại sao đây
A gọi chỉ cần tôi đang bị lập Điệp lại
rồi này
Ừ tôi quý là tây đâu nhỉ
rồi nhưng nếu sử buýt ở đây cho vào
trong như thế này à
Ừ rồi cho Bị sao đấy rồi
à à
Ừ rồi chứ vấn nhiều câu vãi
à À đúng rồi đúng rồi vừa rồi mình Phi
tơ mày không dùng Cái đấy à ok
cả ngày không cần đi tơn cũng được ok à
nhớ hồi trước phải ghi tên thật Khánh
nhớ chắc cô về vụ đấy
Ừ như vậy còn đây nó mới sửa lại có thể
thấy không biết được
ở nhà để sắc thì ông có nuôi tôm về À
đúng rồi còn nói nốt
con cái khái niệm
away này Owen này cái thứ mà nó rất dễ
có thể gây lỗi cho mày ông vì Nếu giả sử
dã sử nhé Tôi dùng nó quay trực tiếp ở
đây như thế này chứ không không thêm cái
que ngày nữa
Ê mày không thể câu truy vấn của tôi
đang như thế nào là tôi trong cho Ngọc
tròn như thế này nhìn như thế này anh
hoặc Mini này Ngoại em mini Còn nếu mà
ông nếu mà ông già xù ông oye Thẳng là
luôn ông không có nằm trong cái que
không nằm trong mặt tròn như này thì có
truy vấn của ông sẽ rất sai vì đây là
một đào cả vụ này ao đây là càng vụ này
em ở đây nữa như thế này mà rỡ sai không
ạ Nên là ông nên cẩn thận về một cái vụ
went này đây cái đấy nhất thứ hai đó là
một cái rất là hay của ori này đó là
vì nếu giả sự mấy ông thấy là hồi hồi
tôi mới học nhé còn bị cái tôi nghĩ là
cả were như này mình phải quen nhé Ai
xong rồi lúc sau mình our ở dưới chứ bởi
vì kiểu 1 trong 2 mà không cần mà ông
chỉ cần ông giiaos một chút cái này cũng
được này
không cần phải lúc đầu phải có một cái
que xong nồi bị bắt đầu mới dưới mình
mới alway rồi
em không Có phải nhà nhá mà ông Oh well
phẳng ngay luôn được này ngay từ đầu
được Kiểu như thế
Anh An Nhưng mà ông thầy cốt của tôi
đang hiện tại này tôi một đống web chứ
không phải là đấy Cái thứ nhất và tương
tự cái đấy nó sẽ sinh ra thêm cả cái
Shake anh xex
ừ ừ
A và snack bình thường cái này tới giờ
Sao bây giờ mày ông đang thấy là tôi
đang không có xe lách thì cả tôi lấy hết
toàn bộ trong cái Porsche ra chỗ in ra
không ạ Đây như này là sự bây giờ tôi
muốn Shake mỗi ID này
Ê bà nêm 1 chọn em
thật sự nhanh
à à
Ừ thì tôi sẽ là xe lách
mới đi rồi
Ừ ừ không truyền truyền Thiếu mà nhưng
mà giả sử là xử thế này xe này đây
a slack ID pass thôi Đúng tôi tôi không
quan tâm cái này nữa thôi quan tâm Cô
chụp gần nhất sẽ eidfjord thôi đúng ạ
đấy Ờ
là chuẩn nhà tôi cá nhân tôi là không
thích dùng để xé rách cả lắm
Bởi vì sao Bởi vì đôi khi là tôi Giả sử
ra xử nha trong trường hợp Quen như thế
này quen Phi Total City Tôi muốn crece
một vài cái nữa là sự thế là sử tôi một
xe lách thêm sự tôi sẽ lách thêm cái ở
đây là cái quần xi hạn
cái gì phát lên xuống rồi à
à à
ghi đè lên cái xe lách cũ là phải salad
hay đi này khi mà ông gọi con sẽ lách là
nó sẽ ghi đè cả sẽ lấy cũ nó không thêm
mới không Không chèn thêm mình sẽ lách
làm
Ừ Thì ông nên dùng appz pack như này Ừ
thì nó mới gọi là ghi đè thêm vào này
ra nếu mà ông để chắc cú là bởi vì cái
cốt này ra xử Tôi sẽ gọi rất nhiều sport
là xử thế rất nhiều lỗ Tôi sẽ gọi thêm
cả scoop khác như là Vân thêm một nhiều
cái nữa thì đôi khi cái này nếu mà ông
ghi cái này vào cái ở cuối Xong sau và
những kẻ xấu kia sự cái Scope trên này
của tôi lại có lại có một cái quay cẩu
xe lách gì gió nữa thì sao tự nghĩa
ngoại nhi đè nó lên nghe cách tốt Nó có
thể ghi là ác select như thế này
ở lại thì nó sẽ hiểu nó sẽ không bao giờ
ông Ông không cần này lúc đầu cũng xe
khách hàng luôn mà ông khi ông bị etylic
là sẽ không được ghi đè lên thằng khác
để tránh lỗi ông ạ
em thậm chí có một cái ra buồn cười hơn
khi mà tôi đọc được đó là cái xe
blackrose
có thể ghi những câu chuyện vẫn bình
thường thuần
phù hợp kiểu dạng là ông muốn dùng Sara
cao hanosimex gì gì đó vẫn Vân ông ghi
câu truy vấn ashworth nhưng thường và
cái xếp lo có điểm hay đó sẽ ra áp selec
trong bài xì dách bình thường sẽ ghi
thêm đề và câu truy vấn của ông đấy là
những cái tôi nói qua mình những cái hàm
của thằng Quân cụ thể bây đi đâu không
rõ nữa biết quần hay quay video nhưng mà
ờ ờ cả hai nó là một máy
ở những cái implement thì thôi Anh nhớ
không lầm mình nhờ ăn cơm mình là của
thằng l Quần còn chạy Hà mát date thì nó
là của quay video rồi Vậy cũng nhỉ
thì tại sao tự tự nhiên nhắc về cái vụ
quần Facebook đô gì ạ
implement làm sao
anh ở đây
xem quay đưa có đấy
32 hàng đều đơn giản em biết thôi nếu mà
nó sẽ gọi đến cái hàm hàm
chị sẽ tự động cậu
ghi cách cách đi của nói cái câu truy
vấn của thằng
số của thằng đấy nó sẽ rất là hay giỏi
như thế này vẫn là bên nhé
anh sex update table từ đó xong rồi xét
chỗ sẽ chính cột đấy nó tăng lên Thôi
cái kiểu
quan Titi
bằng con Titi + đúng cái số mà em muốn
vào là sửa 12 10 đó như này đấy à Ơ cái
thằng in Human là sự tự động viết câu
truy vấn ra thành kiểu dạng như này là
cột đấy cộng thêm cái số em chuyển vào
là như thế thôi
nhau nếu mà lời khuyên thì nha anh bảo
thì vẫn nên biến nó thành đối tượng sau
đó thì mới update người tăng gì đó và
viết theo kiểu đối tượng mà sẽ viết hay
hơn nha có hai kiểu như em Bây giờ thủ
ví dụ luôn nha
để tắm solo này
Ờ Ờ
mình sẽ kẹo là một là tệ trong cái ví dụ
Thì đó để cho bạn ấy sẽ hiểu đi
cái cột gì đấy tăng được nè
có Quốc nào đây tắm nước
ô tô tại number FX apk nhất mình sẽ cho
cái thằng ID này đi mình sẽ có
a What is luôn Ngon phết ai xa sợ ngay
thì mình sẽ ra number
ừ
hát đi cân nha
ê ê
thế
thế này nó gọi luôn này
ừ ừ
ở trại hòm xếp như thế này là khởi tạo
khởi tạo aliquan người ta mua đồ cho
mình sẽ lưu vào lại thì nó sẽ chạy cái
chicle cái nó sẽ kích hoạt cái chữ do
cái even khi mà sếp sếp khi lưu lại này
ha Thì gì đó hãy vần sự kiện Còn nếu mà
ông gọi theo kiểu dạng là Boss
này xong rồi Where ID đúng không ạ bằng
hai 18 năm sau đó thì ông ạ
A Gọi update đi này
Ừ nó vô ý chuẩn luôn này à do như này
ông gọi cái chính cái cột cũ rồi tăng
lên một như thế này đấy thì nó sẽ không
kích hoạt cái Vân 10 kích hoạt với Diva
này xếp này tôi sẽ test thử trong đống
xem nha Tôi thử B d1 ở đây mới ông xem
có chọn nhé
Hà Tiên ơi chạy cái này không ạ lưu lại
này
Ừ thôi à
mở ra một ngoại nghĩa nó kích hoạt vào
tháng ngày
mày đi này tình trạng này nó không kích
hoạt và Thắng Ê thằng Y Vân khi lưu lại
tương tự thế tôi thử đổi nó thành nhà có
hàm y cumin đúng không
đúng chứ
thứ ngày
Em chỉ cần truyền cột này như thế này
thôi sẽ kích hoạt nhé Tôi nghĩ là không
Đâu của việc dùng quay không Rồi nó cái
bị đơ thôi
chạy phát nữa này không biết hoặc không
ạ dù có D đây rồi em trước còn còn tương
tự cũng thế
Ừ ông
được chỗ này
à à
ý kiến mình ngay sếp ngay nó vẫn kích
hoạt nó
hãy quên đi cái mình cái này mới đúng
này à
à Có phải không
anh nói cho ông làm thì tôi khuyên ở nên
kiểu khởi tạo đối tượng với ông chạy sắp
xếp như này tí nữa encasement chạy cái
mặt này nó đã tự động xếp rồi phải
đúng rồi nó ở đâu không Nó tự động xếp
vẫn gọi là chết ấy thì cách cách sửa nó
sẽ ngày một Đông
hình ảnh tôi chỉ ông một là ông làm do
thuần nghe nhé hai ông dùng hàm có sẵn
của nó để mà làm nha bà ông khởi tạo
hiệu quần được mà làm tự động tao Ok chứ
đối tượng thì ông sẽ bắt được rất nhiều
sự kiện thì nó hợp lý hơn là bìa ba tay
mình ở cho mọi thứ mình vẫn còn đang xử
lý nhanh mượt thì mình khởi tạo đối
tượng được vì sao mình cần xử lý tối ưu
theo cậu là tốc độ cần nhanh hơn thì
mình tính em giải pháp và kiểu phải dùng
do dùng Thuận chưa
Ừ ok Bộ hôm nay chắc à rất rất nhiều
kiến thức rồi chắc là tôi có gì tôi sẽ
chia sẻ À đúng rồi phải đỡ được đẩy nút
đã Đầu tiên là mình cập nhật
3 cách đẩy cách đầy cốt nha Xem lại cách
tốt nha
à à ở đầu tiên thì mình luôn kiểm tra
xem mà có những cái Hàn mới tạo hay
không này thì mình sẽ mình sẽ đẩy những
cái hàng mới tạo lên để hấp Ơ lên đấy
tiếp theo là mình sẽ đẩy á
35 à i5 này còn ảnh hưởng có chỗ khác Ừ
đấy nằm lên cũng được này Mày đi năm lên
toàn bộ 5 test thì được ca mình không
được cầm lên đẩy lên
anh đi thôi tôi test ở đây Xóa toàn bộ
cũ không xa những cái tiếp theo mình đẩy
những là controller không quan trọng nên
trước đã
I miss the weather sửa lại mới được quen
này không ảnh hưởng bị độc lập
ở mấy cái này tôi không cần phải con nít
thì mấy vì
chỉ có mỗi Y5 này thích thì ông thấy có
mít thôi Còn mấy cái thằng Tech con chữ
L cập nhật mới được nghe này thì nếu nó
chỉ avi format thì ông một ông ghi tên
là reflect hai ông ghi cụ thể
ông ông đầy nó tự động như thế này còn
một vài cái đấy bác buộc phải điền này
Ừ cái này dài dòng hơn để sau đi cái
ngắn gọn mình thấy nó nữa tôi nghĩ ngắn
gọn để đến trước đẩy lên toàn bộ mấy cái
kiểu tạo
khi truy quét này
thể đặt tên Chung nó nó
đặt tên cho nó là update our
site web à chaque
à Xong rồi Tại quét xong em luôn thêm số
S Nếu nó nhiều lắm
Ừ để mà về sau mình xem cái con nít của
mình xem cái chỗ có mít mới ship của
mình là tiện này cái này là mình sẽ cập
nhật là được cái tự động Điền
đẩy lên mua đồ ấy trước mua đồ là những
cái nó gần như viết những cái hàm để mà
trong container mình dùng cái
ghi thêm app ship ngay cạnh thế
Ừ để lại đã
thế này
chút em nhé
Ừ tôi cũng không nhớ hôm trước đã làm
thì bạn thấy khi comment cơ
Ok Để loạn
A passionate patna Minh là
ờ ờ
update à
à à
ở một đại bồ này
a boss
thích thì thế Tắt bớt đi ông sẽ chị lấy
những cái đoạn này trước đã
lafesta là nó sẽ nó sẽ có khái niệm là
a free Format là để cập nhật lại code
kiểu dạng là kiểu có thể là là kiểu cốt
sửa lại nhìn nó dễ nhìn hơn hay là kiểu
gì đó Chỉnh sửa nói ít hơn nhờ cốt không
thay đổi về cái lôgích của cốt mà chỉnh
sửa nó dễ nhìn hơn không thay đổi lại
lôgic được ạ
phát tơ tất cả nó sẽ bao gồm cả chuyển
đổi cốt từ chỗ này sang chỗ kia hai a
khẩu
à à Cập nhật lại logic
Ừ ông ấy gọi Trung Hòa update được
update đôi khi nó sẽ Nhầm cái J Pasteur
nhưng mà update này là nó sẽ cập nhật
thêm lôgic thường ai thế nó sửa lại cả
lôgic còn còn cái phát tơ này thì nó gần
như là nó không hẳn là sửa lôgic còn sửa
lại cấu trúc của cốt trị giá này cấu
trúc của cốt thì Harry Potter Format là
kiểu chỉ cập nhật có dễ nhìn hơn nhé
nhưng mà vẫn phải nằm trong pha đấy
effect tơ gần như nó có thể tách nhỏ ra
để trong vai khác này bánh nhỏ hàm Vân
tới Theo như tôi hiểu nhé Ừ thôi không
chuyện với mày có mít này lắm
tai nghe Samsung lại thời sự rung lại
với factors cho nó đi à
faster code cần như thế thôi mình không
sửa luôn thích thể loại này cả
mà à
còn đoạn này remove cái gì đó mua đi Ok
ok tất cả được poster các đoạn này sẽ
Ừ dạo này mình sẽ là update à
cần tải tại gì à
Ừ mình không nắm rõ lắm nhưng mà về xử
lý dữ liệu lớn thì công ty mình có đang
làm thì chắc là để mình nói lại để buổi
để buổi sau mình là anh sẽ nói cho mấy
ông về khái niệm sát xác định nhé ra tôi
cũng làm tôi đọc qua một vài bài Thôi
tôi không chuyên làm tôi nói được
Ừ cái gì tôi sẽ nói về chưa
Em hãy nhớ kiến thức của tôi vẫn mới nói
thẳng thì nó mới chỉ đi làm thực tế có
hơn một năm thôi
có kinh nghiệm nó vẫn chưa thực sự nhiều
lắm
anh em
a date ở đây sẽ update Twitter
bộ remote p.bồ
ở
đây sẽ là Lossless nó
Ừ ừ thì tôi mới đi làm hơn một năm thật
Ừ tôi Đùa méo làm gì bởi tôi đi dạy
trước đấy mà tôi đi dạy thôi ở lại
trường dậy luôn mà cứ nhờ tôi cũng sẽ à
Hồi đầy may mà tôi vẫn còn ngồi làm phần
mềm nhà trường nhưng mà đấy tôi tự học
tự làm chứ nó không được tính ở kinh
nghiệm thực tế của vì của việc mình mình
không có trải nghiệm thực tế không có ai
view code không anh cậu chỉ mình đúng
sai như nào Vân thế là gần như là là
khác tự học khả năng tự học của tôi
không kém đó là cũng kém mắt không có
thảm thần thánh gì ở đâu Thôi khẳng định
gọi con nhà người ta gì cả
a post code này nó vẫn rất rối cố này
rất nhiều xử lý Mọi thứ vẫn chưa tối ưu
vân vân
Thế nên là kiểu chỗ hồi mãi về sau tôi
mới hiểu thích rare hơn thôi mình mò hơn
ở chung là nó mới lên được một tí
chỉ ra đặc biệt ở vì tôi ép bản thân
mình giống như bây giờ tôi đang ép bản
thân tôi dậy được mấy ông mà thôi sẽ
phải tự mình ngòi họ thêm Vân cho mình
làm dậy không ạ thì lúc ấy trình tôi mới
lên có nghĩa là đấy một cách hay đó là
mình sẽ cần như mình có độc vừa có động
lực này vừa có áp lực vừa có kiểu dạng
này là thực sự ở đây mình cố để mã thúc
đẩy bản thân mình
Anh hiểu rõ bản chất thì mới dậy được
cái lờ thứ thì nó lên trình thế thôi
khi tôi thấy ở kêu tôi chẳng có gì gọi
là đã ngộ cả tôi nghĩ là tôi thật
cho tôi tôi đơn giản lắm mấy ông gặp
ngoài đời thấy tôi trẻ trâu có đây nhờ
đương nhiên là
Ừ tôi không khẳng định tôi tầm thường
rồi ở tầm thường như thế này nó chẳng có
gì nổi bật thì không Tôi vẫn luôn cố
mình khiến mình nổi bật Có nhưng mà ít
tôi à để hâm mộ thì không về có bà thì
các bạn sẽ đầy phải thế mạnh hơn tôi và
và lập trình cũng không hẳn là một thế
mạnh của tôi lắm
Ừ hôm qua cái đấy Cái thứ tôi đang khiến
tôi nổi bật và dáng kiểu như thế thôi và
anh nói chung là mọi thứ thì tôi thấy
bình thường qua tôi là một người may mắn
được vào cái môi trường ổn để phát triển
ngày và Vân và và kiểu được mọi người
chú ý nó sẽ nổi bật hơn thế thôi I
vật thật anh ấy có trí nhớ tốt Mày học
tốt cho hướng mà không biết được về sau
nếu mà sợ song những câu chuyện của các
bạn kể không biết là tôi sẽ bị sẽ là một
người đáng nhớ như thế nào
À thỉnh thoảng mấy anh em trong yêu tim
thường ngày bàn chuyện tôi cảm thấy hay
lắm đi soi cầu kể về tiểu sử của anh nào
đó các thứ thứ
các kiểu giá cả
Ừ ông ông biết hôm trước à à Kiểu ông
biết ông ABC này Không ông ấy từng làm ở
vị trí nào các từ thứ kể từ sự hay fake
tôi cũng thấy ca tôi cũng khá thích vụ
về sau biết đâu có ai đó ngồi kể với
mình tiểu sử với mình
nản quá toàn thân anh cũng ghét ra
Switch tới doanhtheo bác em nhiều như
thế Anh không biết khuyên em cái gì ở
trong Hòa em nếu mà theo được bác em thì
em cứ nên chuyện với nó Em không cần
phải cố gắng quá đâu nhưng mà đương
nhiên là nếu full sách Giống như mình
bản thân mình tôi ở ghét ra Tuyết nhưng
mình vẫn gọi hiểu mà làm thì vẫn làm
được qua mình không cố động ở nhiều
nhưng mình vẫn thương sách ở trên mobi
Thế làm giao diện thì về ốp về rồi nha
nó xin lỗi xấu nhưng hãy gọi giao diện
nhé Xong rồi có cốt thì cần nhiều có
nhiều người đi trước mà mình có thể tham
khảo code người ta để mình sửa lại theo
ý mình để cho hợp lôgích là được còn bác
em mình chuyên bán nhanh hơn
không ạ Thực ra thì
Ẩm Thực tế tôi từng nghĩ là mấy cái vụ
đấy Thì thực tế toàn bộ mở cái fan
wordless nó đã là độc lập so với với
người Bắc em rồi nên là ông áp dụng
Facebook nào được Từ view Từ Từ view từ
Iraq Từ Angola Hệ vân vân
Không sao cả đấy thì nó độc lập rồi
khi mở lock lập đây nhá nên nó không
dùng để trị được nhưng đứng yên à Có vài
thằng này nó hỗ trợ mẹ hơn một tí thôi
không quan trọng về mấy vụ để làm đâu
Ừ nếu muốn kiểm tra tài khoản gồm user
name và bắt có tồn tại thì mình lên
selects username trước để kiểm tra rồi
mình đến password hay sẽ lấy cả hai cùng
lúc luôn Ai Ờ
mình kiểm tra bằng à
ừ ừ
ai dọn nhà nghỉ
chỉ có vài nơi thì kiểm tra cả hai có
phải nơi kiểm tra một cái trước quan
trọng cái cái bài toán kiểm tra cả hai
thì nó sẽ
Ừ nó đứng yên là sẽ lâu hơn sau kiểm tra
một cái
độ phản hồi nhanh thì kiểm tra một cái
rồi thông báo về luôn Nhưng các bạn vẫn
luôn luôn phải thông báo là ra tùy tùy
có vài nơi thông báo hẳn luôn là tài
khoản không có số tài khoản có cái tên
này tồn tại Có đấy Có vài nơi luôn cảnh
báo về chung chung là là đạt hiệu dạng
là
đấy lỗi tên đăng nhập hoặc mật khẩu đúng
ạ Cái thường kiểm tra một cái trước
em thậm chí ở hội trước à có cái vụ là
kiểu mình là
thì mình phải mã hóa cả cả password rồi
mình mới kiểm tra cản và đoạn Mã mã hóa
xử lý do nên đôi khi mình sẽ kiểm tra
username trước tồn tại người bắt đồ Ừ
mình mới bắt đầu lấy cái mật khẩu ra cho
mình mã họa mình giải mã để mà so sánh
hỏi mình mã hóa thì so sánh cái kiểu như
thế nhiều có nhiều cho ông thích xử lý
nhất là thôi
bây giờ Ông hỏi tôi là biết mày thấy gì
gì gì đó thì tôi đi chịu
thật sự là như thế
Ừ tôi không nhớ tên nó lắm mà tội không
tìm hiểu về rất nhiều người cá thử
anh em ấy thế nên tôi bảo là thức ăn à
Anh em cho chứ tìm học hỏi được người
khác tốt và biết được tiểu sử người khác
này nói chung nhà người ta người ta ra
ngoài được là ra giỏi người ta biết được
rất nhiều người giỏi khác về mà kiểu
ngưỡng mộ và học hỏi nữa đấy tụi anh
Tuấn là khỏi anh Tuấn Người nào biết
admin của cách lớn Hà
sio2 gió biết hết mấy người nói chỗ nào
cũng gọi là giỏi mà nào biết tiểu sử
người ta đều nóng rõ Còn tôi đi chịu
anh hơi buồn điểm đấy tôi người cả ngày
thôi chứ chẳng đọc tín hiệu elie mấy
di comment system không còn chưa biết
cái cái gì Điều tra Phát ạ
Ừ cái bài toán hệ thống gợi ý Ok Ok
Ừ cái này thì đâu quan trọng đâu tùy xem
mà em muốn làm cái cái này không thôi mà
đâu quan trọng là kiểu ba em cần phải
học thêm cái này đâu Ờ
Em ở chỗ nào trang của em có có cần cái
này thì em học thôi tôi lưu đại tướng
đọc thêm
bởi vì trang của tôi cho thương mại từ
master-k chính tôi là người làm cái vụ
này luôn rồi nhưng mà cái y ý tưởng hay
mọi thứ rồi cần phải gợi ý nào thì xếp
tôi làm và xếp Tôi nghĩ và giao tôi Tôi
không cần phải đọc kỹ rồi mày này như
cái này hay để tôi thử đọc xem thế nào
nếu đôi khi ở nó liên quan thực quá
nhiều kiểu như tôi bắt đầu thấy hơi hoa
mắt này anh tưởng thế
Ừ thôi nói chung ở bữa mày cho tặng dừng
lại đây à Có gì thì
Mọi người thắc mắc thì nhắn tin bình
luận sau nha cho mấy ông nhé
đó là thứ tôi nhớ lại ở thứ năm thứ Bảy
thì bây giờ sẽ biến hàng nhà buổi à
ở buổi ạ chữa đồ ăn nhá Còn buổi nói
chung nhà buổi thứ ba sẽ buổi làm màu
nhà gấu ngồi giới thiệu thêm được cốt
luôn cái cố thì sao cho vợ chuyên nghiệp
trong mỗi cái còn nhưng mà những buổi
kia tôi sẽ phải chữa đùa nữa mới ông để
mấy ông mấy ông cần biết phải làm gì tôi
cảm thấy con nhiều nhau Nó bị chậm quá
đi nhé
à à